(audience applauds)
- What is going on in this pic
with your "Blackish" co-star Deon Cole,
who I love.
- [Anthony Anderson] Ha!
- I just need to know
- Ha! Ha! Ha! Ha!
- like, look at
- Look at my belly.
(Anthony laughs)
- I mean, you're obviously doing Prince.
(all laugh)
- Okay. I didn't know
you were showing that.
- I love that we see
something that others don't.
I didn't even think about,
and, I'm looking at the
whole freaking picture.
- [Anthony] Look at my navel.
(all laugh)
- I gotta be honest with you,
I would look identical if I put that on
- right now.
- Okay.
- No, that was.
- Well, you're doing Prince, obviously.
- Yeah, yeah. We're doing Prince.
That was "Blackish's" hundredth episode.
And, the entire episode
was an ode to Prince.
- Yeah.
- And, that's what we did.
- I love Deon.
- Oh, Deon's the best.
- He's so funny and kind.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He is.
- He's cool.
- Deon Cole. I love you, brother.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. That's my brother.
- And, he keeps it real, too.
I know he has been going through
a lot of life situations.
- Yeah.
- And, I like that he's honest about it,
because people in the
public eye, you know,
you look up to people that
you love seeing on shows,
whatever.
And, when they break down
the smoke of mirrors, it's nice.
It makes everybody feel connected.
- I think that's really nice.
- Mm-hmm.
- Oh no, definitely.
- Yeah. I love him.